[Music]
I think the role that I have helped
bring to this space is bringing people
together and so I think through my work
at posit I saw that so many of these
pharmaceutical companies just wanted to
get together they wanted to talk and
they were coming to me to say can you
make these introductions so starting our
and Pharma was really the spark that
brought a lot of the pharmaceutical
companies together and there for the
first time the r validation Hub had
their hangout uh you know ideas around
the farm diverse were sparked out of the
idea that these pharmaceutical companies
had specific workflows and code that
they wanted to share so it's been
amazing to really just see the life that
has come out of the RN Pharma conference
there was very much this sense and
momentum that a New Horizon was coming
out for open source to change the
landscape and lead to a lot of
Innovations for clinical trials and so a
lot of groups that had implemented R for
research or for shiny had now started
saying can we use this in addition for
our late stage clinical trials work I
could certainly feel that there was a
change coming to the way that clinical
trials were conducted in bringing open
source to that ecosystem but I knew that
it was going to take some time and there
was going to be a decent amount of
change management that would have to
take place for that to work part of the
popularity of our in the drug
development space especially late stage
clinical trials is because there was a
legacy stat programming language that
people had used and so migrating from
that language to R was a very easy
transition for a lot of organizations
because R is an open source language
built for statistical Computing as well
as that Legacy code and programming tool
was also built for stats programming so
I think the transition from that
previous tool to R is natural because
languages like python are more general
purpose programming languages and so I
think that has led to a lot of the
adoption in the space as well as shiny I
would say a lot of pharmaceutical
companies use our professional software
for their clinical trials and that
typically consists of posit team and
posit team is made up of three different
products there's a posit workbench which
is the development environment literally
it's called a development environment
because it's where people are going to
go in and do their programming there
they create software and artifacts and
content and shiny apps and workflows and
then they move that into production into
our second product which is called posit
connect that's the production and
deployment platform that we host and
maintain and then the back end what's
surfacing out the production and
oftentimes validated packages for both
of those environments is the posit
package manager and so that's feeding
packages for reproducibility into the
development side as well as feeding
packages into the production side
pharmaceutical companies care a lot
about positive package manager because
there is this great desire to own and
manage the validation and oftentimes
what's referred to as qualification of
packages and so a lot of work goes
internally at pharmaceutical companies
to say these are the core packages
typically around 100 to 2 or 300 or so
packages that this is what people are
going to use for clinical trials so
package manager specifically is critical
for clinical development because it
makes the source of where their package
is coming from locked down and approved
for the work internally at the company
yeah there's a lot of use cases and
companies and pharmaceutical
organizations using our professional
tools recently this was highlighted by
Satish Murthy in the data science
hangout that they use positive package
manager for surfacing and managing the
source of their validated packages that
they bring out that's one of the most
key things for organizations is to make
sure the source of the package is coming
into the workflows is validated and the
right packages in addition to that Merck
also had a webinar with us that
highlighted their use of package manager
there's lots of other organizations that
have highlighted the use of posit
connect for where they manage and host
their shiny applications for example
Roche and Genentech in their webinar a
couple months ago highlighted that they
have an entire framework that they've
built in-house around shiny and they
host their shiny apps there with posit
connect it's going to be interesting to
see how the future plays out with
introductions to new tooling like Python
and leading that into Ai and how some of
that could change some of the clinical
trials I don't think that's going to
happen right away but we see this very
big inclusive and interoperable future
for drug development
foreign